debate the internet i feel like i'm  doing a [ __ ]  old school talk show you have a choice  between a sum of money  and world peace how much money would you  would it take for you to give up  world i go for a world peace period end  of story everyone's got a number  no 200 billion no no no dude i'm doing  great i have enough of them  the american i would absolutely i read a  thing today you know  cover the paper how in cashmere they're  doing something there  and this woman's son 22 got bit by a  snake and couldn't get past the people  to get in  just seeing the mother's anguish there's  a number  well i don't think there's enough i  don't think oh you went big  there's not enough wild wings do i got a  number